yeah i hit the go live and it's a
youtube account not enabled for
streaming
all right let's start breaking him down
now he's not going to have the same tank
as you all right let's put it on both
hands
just a beautiful display of boxing rich
to the body on that one then comes with
the uppercut doesn't really know which
angle the jaw is going
and you heard jason pirillo acknowledge
these notorious slow starts for cheeto
vera there might be a method though to
the madness well i mean you don't want
to like
down
someone who is naturally a lighter
fighter i don't think that that is
necessarily the case because you're
fighting someone of such a high stature
who has been around the block a couple
of times so i think that liam smith
definitely showed what he had
so
you can hear me
i don't see me
let me see
oh there we go it was just showing that
i was live oh thank god people my bad
so right now um the fight is supposed to
be going on right now and i'm um i'm
clicking it in the head uh thanks now
though that's what's up i appreciate
everything
this is the growing pains of doing it by
yourself and don't worry i'm gonna have
moderators and stuff like that soon i'm
just uh fixing stuff up because i send
my payment i'm just trying to figure out
how come i'm not streaming the actual
fight so
hold on that's what i'm doing now and i
was trying to see why i wasn't showing
live because i had the channel up but
the channel wasn't showing so
don't worry about it guys i'm still
working on the situation
i'm going to fix the situation but again
this is the prelims we didn't even get
to what we drinking and what's going on
for the evening
so
again
we had the zone fight go down with uh
vargas versus beefy and uh this is attic
right now calling me uh i'm going to
mute myself
[Music]
in the very beginning he held that same
energy throughout the entire fight
coming forward with this jab slow
stocking tight tight guard throwing to
the body throwing to the head vargas had
good movement early on but after he got
hit after he got cut he stopped moving
as much
start to see bargains backing up to the
ropes here as liam continues to go to
the head goes to the castle
[Music]
yeah so apologize guys trying to do this
joint right now trying to fix the stuff
hold on one second so again
um we have one fight beefy one pulse uh
over on the zone um let me get into
all this other stuff i had five
different fights running at one time
and i'm trying to get to the stevenson
uh valdez fight all right so um let me
head over to that
and um worse come to worse
uh i'll set up something separate
to actually do that because
there's like four different ufc fights
going on tonight
and it was two different boxing matches
going on as well
so
i'm trying to knock all of that stuff
out at one time
and listen guys uh growing pains of the
channel is going to get absolutely
better
and it's going to be absolutely
way better especially when i can uh
get another moderator in here with me to
help me out on certain things so don't
y'all worry about that we're going to
dig into this fight with valdez and
uh stevenson
um
let me see
i'm gonna have to probably
go to espn
separate
and um
do an extra pay through
because um
i mean i'm having a little bit of an
issue
here so let me um type that in
espn pay-per-view how come my
whatchamacallit didn't go through
check on my payment
all right i don't want to see that
i want to see
my boxing okay
so give me my boxing
you know what's crazy about espn they
put boxing on the side and it kind of
sucks that you don't get a chance to see
um
your stuff is it's really bad it's like
they put basketball on everything front
center
and they put boxing over to the side
like it's you know nondescript
okay so you know this is really stupid
i have everything here
hold on a second guys
check your passwords
um
this is this is why you don't sign up
for streaming services
you know um let me tell you man
the first thing that they do is they
take your money
and then
later on
you're looking to do what you're
supposed to do
and you're having a hard time with it
this is gonna be legendary
you guys gonna have jokes
and i'm cool with it
okay
[Music]
that's good
all right let me change that
i'm trying to get this done
as fast as possible but the fight isn't
starting yet so don't even worry about
it
the fight will probably start probably
like around midnight
and i'm signing in right now
this is ridiculous
this is absolutely ridiculous this is
absolutely the worst thing that can
actually happen
i do not want to use that email address
stupid
that's the email address
send me just send me the stuff man
this is oh my god this is like a
nightmare on top of a nightmare
wrapped into another nightmare
okay let's get back down here okay so
i'm into my account
back into everything i'm going to be
reading the chats very soon
it doesn't get much better than
this i cannot believe that the time is
finally here katie taylor versus amanda
serrano and madison
no
that's not what we're talking about you
see what i'm talking about this is
oh my god
absolute nightmare absolute nightmare
they let me into my zone account
with no problem
he left me into my bellator account
with no problem
my espn account
huge problem
don't worry guys i'm right here
i'm gonna do everything
right here
we're going to
[Music]
over here
all right so we're gonna do uh the zone
right now while i
pull up my account my espn account on my
phone
slightly bigger
work with the espn account on my phone
right now i'm gonna knock this out
really quick
i know actually i do know
is
[Music]
and it should be showing on my
television
my laptop
so the setup is this right um we have uh
two monitors here
and
you know one of the podcasts one is the
the show actually being done and then we
have uh the laptop on the side streaming
the fight
until i get the hot power pc rig
upstairs and then y'all can actually
look at this stuff upstairs
what's going on people
i know i know i know
all right here we go
so right now amanda serrano is uh coming
up on the zone card and
that that isn't going to actually be a
fantastic fight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the fighters they're in the background
right now because the earlier fight
uh ended too early
so beefy like i predicted um
[Music]
vargas i knew vargas came in kind of
soft his body didn't look right um he
looked like he just showed up for
paycheck and that's kind of dangerous
but i mean i guess he gave his uh some
of his all
world champion and amanda serrano it's
live from the mecca of boxing your
commentary team for our main event this
evening
all
right can barely hear our team upstairs
the crowd is so loud whether they show
katie or whether they show amanda
everybody is super excited i don't care
about them
flags from each country it's insane
what's gonna happen in the rick forget
all this stuff because once the bell
ratters rings it doesn't matter it's not
what i want oh man
i just want the pay-per-view see they're
trying to get me to
sign back up with espn and that was the
problem when i paid for the pay-per-view
i paid for the pay-per-view straight out
so now they're trying to get me
chris what are we
signing back up with them in my
streaming service and that's not what i
want amanda serrano is the bigger
puncher she is going to want to have
something of a fight and a phone booth
where they trade punches in the middle
of the ring katie taylor is the better
pure boxer more of an athlete at her
best she's moving a little bit in and
out using the totality of the ring to
her advantage
not
[Music]
i don't even have my drinks here
[Music]
[Music]
all the
ufc's are going that's but that's not
the fight with that we here for
we're here for the oscar valdez fight
and um
this guy fight
asking about this stevenson fight
that's out there
all right i work very very hard to be in
the position that i am there we go and
i will do whatever it takes to come out
victorious
if i gotta train
jesus you want to talk about scaring
somebody half to death
yeah that's actually terrifying
especially
when you feel like okay you know you
paid your breath now it kicked in
if they break my jaw 21 people what's up
what's going on people
say something so let me see let me see
what up king
chat now watching the fight here just
the vibe with y'all let's see what
you're doing for work thank you brother
do you really want this
let me see so
early on um just sort of tequila that i
picked up tequila's though it's actually
incredible
um
[Music]
and
that's not our music so what i'm using
you're not gonna know about it because
they didn't sponsor me so whenever they
sponsor me they can actually
you know
get that watching color done
so they're showing like a promo of oscar
valdez right now
uh
and um
we got a couple of fighters coming up to
the ring right now i'm really interested
in a lot of fights this evening
you got a ton
of fights
that's that's you know oh you got
muhammad ali's grandson who's actually
coming up to the ring right now um
versus zebra so uh nico nico nico
reminds me of keith thurman
if anybody remember one time thurman
very early on
that's who nico reminds me of and he
actually shows a lot of flashes of keith
thurman you remember young keith thurman
uh when he used to have his head and the
braves going back to the ponytail and he
was doing his thing
so that's who nico reminds me of and
that humble way of himself before keith
thurman got married that's that's
exactly who he reminds me of
and he
he absolutely
fights like a young keith thurman uh he
throws very good punches uh
his combination style is very unique
where keith thurman always thought was
an athletic fighter uh opposed to a
a pure boxer
so he uses a lot of his shoulders in his
movements that's why
when danny broke his elbow it made a lot
of sense why
that fight was real tight for um
for keith thurman
tell my wife to bring me down some sunny
delight you know i like the sunny the
light
[Music]
so you missed
so what i'm doing right now is it's like
a watermelon sunrise the watermelon
sunrise you got sorak watermelon summer
uh summer blast and you mix that with a
little bit of tequila and i mean um no
these ketones later oh mix that with a
little bit of sunny delight so that's
what's up
oh you can hear me baby yes yes yes
please
bring me down the um
the red sunny delight i thought i had
grabbed it when i was coming downstairs
i wanted the the strawberry one i'm
talking to her
dragon yobe what's good baby
that's my dude man i appreciate each and
every last one of you see mac what's
going on
yeah babe let me know when you're coming
downstairs so i can block my camera so
you can just come down and just
and bring me the uh
this is
hold on baby
yeah that's that little box right there
all right that's my emotes
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome
presents the featured event of the
evening
[Music]
as tonight
[Music]
lights off can't talk happy with the
light y'all might win might lose or
might draw
welcome to the combat talk haters in
love but it come back salt if you really
want it in the ring
i had to put that there so y'all can um
didn't see it like a black screen
yeah i'm sit down with my boy graphic
guarding and get a coming uh timeout
hopefully have somebody get knocked out
or whatever i'll be right back and he
like oh
getting punched in the draw so all right
so this would this what it should look
like all right so it should look like
this after you uh you know mix the
soraka at the bottom you know you know
you have to have a little not too much
don't get crazy and you know um
you put the sunny delight to have the
different colors of sunny to like
shout out sunny delight like a
sponsorship what's up
but it's extremely early dad madison
square garden
uh
this nico is coming out first
and i really don't expect this fight to
go the distance i think i think this
fight honestly
with nico
would probably go
four rounds
um
he looked good at the
warm-ups uh
i i've i've been studying a lot of
things with him he has a lot of
superstitions a lot of you guys may not
know that nico drives around with um
a doll in his car
all right so he drives around with his
uh it's
this little doll i forgot what he calls
him i think it's carlos or something
like that
and
it has a mike tyson uh like drawn tattoo
on its face
and a little beard
he looks dope
but he keeps him around all the time so
you know weird superstitions like that
keeps people going
and um
i i want to see what he's going to do if
he's going to follow in the footsteps of
his great grandfather which is muhammad
ali you never know what's going on
yeah yeah whatever omar what's going on
yeah the sunny d is good for me pause
that's what's up
now yo yo see mac yo see matt come on
man stop playing
but it's dope it's dope all right so um
right now they're just showing clips of
um
valdez and they showing uh clips of
stevenson right so
i think honestly
stevenson and haney used to be neck and
neck to me and the only thing that
separated stevenson
uh
from
devin haney to me was the fact that
stevenson had no purpose with his shots
and devin haney to me seemed like he
slapped with his shots more
but
once um i saw
haney fight jojo diaz
jojo's not know
is not a joke um
ryan um
was gonna fight him and you know pulled
out of the fight
david haney has been calling everyone
the same thing we should call stevenson
he's been calling everyone as well
he's a champion devin haley is a
champion and you start to get this uh
distinctions between the the two
fighters you know the african-american
yeah they're young
and that's where the separation starts
to happen separation starts to happen
because they both box the punches but
one has a little bit more snap now i'm
gonna tell you something oscar valdez
has been battle tested
he's in canelo's camp right so he's
trained by eddie reynoso and everybody
also uh
teaches a certain level of combinations
and expects a certain
level of
professionalism when it's like making it
to the gym and stuff like that that's
why ryan garcia didn't work out over
there to be honest with you
because
you know
valdez
he's not a media sensation he's not an
instagram dude so
he's going to go in and he's going to
put in all the work that renoso wants
him to put in
and give 100
i think valdez is more battle tested
than stevens
especially uh the fight that he had the
broken jaw i think he hits harder he
snaps harder with his shots
he's a quiet assassin
but
stevenson has that sauce that that that
little special uh jonah sequoia that you
put in in fighters that you see and you
know something looks a little bit
different he has a little bit of a
pizzazz a little bit of a step step push
push he has a little bit of that and i
honestly expect him
to try to step on about this okay so
when i'm telling you that a fighter is
stepping on somebody that means he's not
giving up ground and he's taking ground
so that means he's stepping and he keeps
stepping him and he's tracking him he's
hunting him he's stepping in so i really
expect him to
step on valdez and try to push valdez
back
i expect valdez to hold his ground and
if valdez holds his ground and he cracks
back
on um shaquar stevenson
then we're we're in for a treat we're
for something really special because now
we're going to get a chance to see
exactly what shakur is made of you know
to be honest with you what's up barbecue
sauce it's my dude
oh yeah yeah see my kitty they actually
did spawn each other all these kids
sparked each other ryan garcia sparta
with all these dudes they remember they
grew up all in the same circus so okay
when you're in these circuits
you see the same faces over and over
again right and um
um so
i don't know what my wife is talking
about she texts me right now
she's watching
um i have absolutely uh
no idea that but um all these dudes they
they spar and they fight each other and
they all in the same circuit you grow up
around these dudes so when they tell you
that who guys fought crawford and in the
amateurs and he beat crawford two times
in amateurs these dudes go around
fighting each other
sean porter
fought a light heavyweight
uh in the amateurs to get up to the
boxing trials
uh these dudes um
they they get in where they fit in they
mix it around and they know each other
and then when they get to the pros
you base all that information that you
learn
in these camps on
them fighting these they they circle the
drain on each other and they know each
other very well ryan garcia is sparred
with uh countless of these dudes and and
vice versa so what you what you want to
do is you want to take your age bracket
because you're fighting age brackets so
you want to take your age bracket and
your age bracket dominate
and that's what we're seeing now so
we're seeing the shaco stevensons and
ryan go see as the tank davis and and
and these characters uh start to
dominate uh their age bracket and and
they're starting to push out the older
guys like you know pacquiao you got to
go spence and crawford in them there and
keith thurman and danny garcia and sean
porter they're part of the different age
bracket you know you got the jerome
boots anders's and uh those people of
the world coming up to push them out so
you got shakur
um
he's he's he's this this is his make it
a break at the moment to be honest with
you both or both of them are
uh have an o in their um their lowest
column
so somebody oh tonight got to go
right i don't i don't see it ended in a
draw i don't see it uh
ending in a dq
i see the fight ending in either
and i'm gonna get my prediction as we
get closer as i see them uh get warmed
up because they both made weight there
was a scare which of course stephenson
and he had to get naked at the podium
pause
and um
you know
they brought up the joint for him to
stand behind uh for him to make weight
so
remember the rules is if you don't make
weight right there you have i think it's
an hour or two to go make weight then
you gotta put on the sauna suit get on
the bike and they give you some
diuretics to make you poop and um make
you make weight make your pee make you
poo whatever you know hopefully you make
weight it just be by a couple ounces but
if your pound's over then either you
know you can get penalized you can strip
to your title and a lot of things like
that can happen but now so again
nico is fighting another person in the
chain going up to be coming a star so
you know the promoter dollars is behind
nico at the moment right now
um i think his fighter the fighter he's
fighting is like i i bear off or
something like that i'll get his name
right i do apologize this is the first
time i'm seeing this fighter and again a
lot of times people are just fighting
just you know just to get the check in
here in here just standing there what's
up
you guys
you said you got your call by
decapitation
be careful don't bet no money right now
until actually i give my prediction
actually i see what they're looking like
because
i'ma tell you
there's a high possibility because
shakur is an unknown commodity right
there's a high possibility
that valdez cracks
how does he react if he gets cracked we
already know if valdez gets cracked
he fought with a broken jaw to 12 rounds
a broken jaw
that's something muhammad ali did with
ken norton
you know very few people has been able
to pull that off imagine getting punched
in your face
with a broken jaw
and then you go on 12 rounds
so we already know that he made of a
different material that man is made of a
different stuff so you're gonna have to
pull him off to get him out of that part
um
do we know that about shakur
is is that shakur's makeup is that your
core stock is is that what he's built
from we're going to find out if that's
what he's built from because if that's
not what he's built from then tonight
gonna be a long night for the kid but i
think he has the athleticism to do some
things so i'm gonna save my prediction
to right before the fight starts and
then when the fight starts i give you my
prediction
what up going on what up what up
was this too dope what up
yeah this fight is hard to call
blessings kenneth
mr frost
um this this fight is hard to call
because this is the true 5050 pick and
fight they both champions they both got
o's
and one take one way to get to the
stardom the other one took another way
to get to the stardom
we don't know we're going to find out
we're going to see exactly what it is
but
there's always going to be a victim
there's always going to be a loser yeah
i may be hedging my bets a little bit
that's that is so dope man i have 37
people and 37 likes i swear to god
that feels so dope man be honest with
you that feels so dope
all right so nico's starting right now
and you know the camera's on nico of
course
they would hope that's a promoter's
dream right you got the greatest of all
time great grandson in the ring
like like that's that's a promoter's
dream and if he's actually decent
so again um
nico's on his back foot uh circling and
throwing the right hand
jabbing jabbing going to the body he's
doing good work
like i said he looks like keith thurman
the second coming of keith thurman a
hungry young keith thurman remember when
keith demon was one time
that's what he reminds me of he moves
with the same movement the same arms the
same pull back his head when he throws
his jab so right now nico's is circling
idera and he's throwing the jab and if
you can hook off the jab you're great
and he's showing that he can hook off
the jab
he's rushing a couple of his shots
he's throwing right hands ibiroff is
there to be hit he's um you know moving
from side to side
but uh nico's trying to land the right
hand and he's dancing around with his
hands down
um i would take a lot of the bad habits
out of him i see a lot of the bad habits
like he's leaning
on his uh lead foot too much
so you know he could be set up for
uppercut or you know um if you actually
uh close the distance on him you can pin
his hand
and he's flat-footed on the front foot
because his heel is down flat so
um
yeah so if he's a boxer puncher but he's
still like i said moving like keith
thurman it reminds me of him
and um he's stalking now he's hitting
him to the body he's smothering his work
i don't like that he dips out a lot with
his hands to his side
but he also showing a discipline when he
does close the gap and plays from his
position
see now right now um
ibero has him up against the ropes and
um
nico's uh fighting off the ropes
good jab good right hand
and he fought him off the ropes to you
know get back to the center of the ring
we had a minute in in in the first round
to go
you know good good air jabs good range
finders
um nothing too special nothing too
flashy he does a lot of dip downs a lot
of lows he's trying to find himself as a
boxer um
i honestly would
would tell him to watch a lot of keith
thurman
uh i thought early keith thurman
actually did some good work i thought he
was really good
um ibera is uh
he has his hands up like earmuffs
in the middle of the ring the center of
the ring he's he's given as good as he
gets he's trying but you can also
understand that the level of competition
isn't the same
oh knocked my coat he hit him he hit him
with a right hand knocked to my coat
nico
hit him with a straight right hand
around the glove and knocked him out
cold
first round knockout absolutely stunning
knockout to see a brutal knockout oh
my god um i'm gonna tell you right now
anybody that's watching take a sip
because that right there was definitely
worthy muhammad ali's grandson is in the
building he's definitely putting his
claim
and taking a stick right there that was
dope
that step that was absolutely dope oh my
god wow
that that came out of nowhere it was a
lazy jab and he spun the right around it
and hit him it was a looping straight
right hand
alco
out
coat reminds you of a young keith
thurman
my god
that looked spectacular
wow i mean absolutely crazy yo if y'all
are watching the fight right now
on god
yo imax that was crazy right
yo
yo that was absolutely sick
that's that's yo 40 40 people here 46
likes respect man oh god thank you so
much i do appreciate each and every last
one of you dear god look at the right
hand boom looping right hand straight
down the pipe laid him he brought the he
brought the jab brought his hand down
and looped him boom because he was
trying to hook with him
dear god
set up was crazy
i told you
there was two levels of competition
set them up boom
set them up
absolutely nuts the layout is crazy
dope
right here here it is
dang
straight on the boy has power the boy
has get him up out of here um he has to
get him up out of here and that's that's
all you want to see in a young fighter
is get him up out of here that can mask
a lot of deficiencies hopefully he
doesn't fall in the trap of a lot of
young fighters they get these knockouts
on these fighters that they're supposed
to get knockouts on and rely on that
hopefully he goes right back to the gym
because he didn't do i mean come on
right right he could be back to the gym
on tuesday right he'd get his mail at
night shake his tail at the club and on
tuesday you back in the gym you you back
doing your road work because you didn't
really put into nothing right here so
hopefully he get back on his due
diligence and get it poppers
oh yeah yo listen
um i'm gonna give you the analysis of
the fight uh and i'm gonna tell you
exactly how i see it from my perspective
and obama help you out as much as
possible but niko's that dude like
nico's that that up and coming so a lot
of times if you want to hit your wagon
to a star
trust me bob aaron has definitely
hitched his rag into the taniko he he
promoted muhammad ali which is his great
grandfather so
this is an honor uh for bob to have
and look at that 250 of the first round
it was 10 seconds left oh boy didn't get
out the first round
and wow
that that was
really really dope to see
the young man has a hell of a future
this is on the big stage i think this is
his first pay-per-view card that he's on
and you know of oh or probably being on
show fights a lot of times dudes is on
undercards that you don't get to see
prelims that started early in the day
and they don't get a chance to be on the
actual camera so
now you know he gets the chance to be
the first fight on the the show fights
the fights that actually uh presented to
the public so
yeah man uh that's that's that's
actually incredible man it's incredible
but how a lot of these blood is strong
he has fighters in his blood
excuse me
his daughter his great grandson i'm
pretty sure he has other lineage that
has tried or is trying
ridiculous let me see what y'all saying
in there
my family my grandfather the legacy i
got you imax man
i got your imax man i just want to bring
back the phil you know the phil me
cognito sovereign all of us who used to
watch fights on uh saturday we get
together and we watch fights
i'm a fight junkie this stuff is in my
blood
i go to the gym first thing i do is make
sure that they got a heavy bag and a
speed bag i hit my jump rope i put on my
signing suits and i can i can lose my
weight i can get back down you know drop
a little 40 pounds 30 pounds real quick
get back to where i need to be
never too afraid to do my sit-ups my
push-ups my road work and stuff like
that so that stuff stays with you
you know but um
like see what nico's explaining he said
he was setting him up with the right
hand he was setting them up but he was
doing a little bit sloppily and like i
said when you have power when you get
that get them up out of there
it can mask a lot of your deficiencies
right so what nico did was he started
off with a high guard and he pulled
himself in now when you do that you're
expecting the opponent to throw
something to break your guard
he capitalized he was doing a counter he
saw him throwing a certain shot he threw
his left hook to get in there with the
left hook jab
and once he he landed the left hook jab
he knew to automatically throw the two
that's called the one two and he on he
knew automatically to throw uh the two
right after that as soon as he landed
the one he threw the two right behind it
and that was the two that caught him so
a lot of times uh you're taught to have
a perfect one two that's why you're
standing at the back you're hitting a
one two and then you throw the three one
two then you throw the three
and the three is either a hook or um
a straight to the body so depending on
what your trainer wants you to do and
what your trainer wants you uh to work
on in any given fight but again
really quick
really fast remember the earl spence uh
uga's uh undercard
those fights went really quick as well
remember that those those fights was
boom boom boom boom boom so
maybe we might get this fight before 12
o'clock
hopefully i think so
yes sir don king is still promoted uh
late for dinner
he's old
him and bob arum
is uh still promoting uh carl king which
is don king's son probably does the bulk
of his work uh at a point in time um
i had a little bit of dealings with uh
carl king um
so
yeah yeah yeah don king is definitely
still promoting he's still promoting
some heavyweights here and there he gets
paid same thing with uh you know bob
aaron bob arum is a big fish out there
paul's you know
he's he's he's one of the the last of
the big promoters that actually know how
to run the game
so um you know you have eddie hearn out
there and his father
thomas hearn i believe his father's name
is thomas hearn um
but eddie hearn is out there
running his uh his the zone stuff and
then
you have the pvc
uh and numbers over there that's uh
running now with al haymon
which is one hell of a promoter
so you know yeah don king does his thing
what up c mac what do you say
he said which sucker still gets promoted
by don king
if don can came to you right now uh c
mac can he tell you yo listen you can go
through a chitlin circuit and i can take
you down south and we can run the
chiclet circuit and you can have at
least uh uh 20 fights by the end of the
year and i'm going to pay you every time
you get this he starts slick talking you
you start talking about this side and
that side dog can come with a check in
the bag for you man hey man you never
know man lights off you might be outside
fighting in the chicken circuit i don't
care money green donkey whatever he is
however old he is he's money good we all
good let's go
he said you get promoted by don king
you're trying to get robbed
every promoter is in your wallet
see the reason why everybody keeps
saying that don king is a robber
allegedly he was doing practices of
double dipping
when you double dip that means uh your
promoter and
you also getting manager fees so you
know you're going into the
the fighter's pocket that way
a lot of these dudes is uneducated when
it comes to money a lot of these dudes
don't have family around them a lot of
these dudes are desperate
and they're expecting you know um
somebody that sees them only as a
commodity to have their best interests
at heart and
that's the wrong attitude to have but
again i don't fault the fighters because
the fighters weren't taught money
management
and uh these promoters know
how to you know fast talk somebody into
a contract and
these dudes don't have lawyers and stuff
like that so i it's very sad and it is
very few fighters that actually know
they were have good people behind them
to help them and guide them through
different things so i'm pretty sure don
king did right by good people by a lot
of people but also maybe he did wrong by
people that allowed it remember you can
only get done bad by people that are a
lot that you allow that that stuff to
happen with so
that's it right now they're showing a
clip about oscar valdez
and um he's
yo i'm
more and more
i'm leaning towards valdez
it's nuts
my wife picked valdez
she said uh uh
you know you know
how women are she's like who do you pick
the the the mexican guy the black guy
i'm like of course i got to go black
that was stupid i was lying i didn't say
that i said he's from jersey
i said he's from jersey i got to take
all he from brick city
but um
you know you got to have that that new
york pride that area of pride
but again
your boxing iq tells you certain things
when you see them fight when you see
them
mixing up your boxing iq tells you
certain things valdez
has what you want your fighter to have
the ability to dig deep inside your body
to bring out more than what you actually
are
and the willingness to be inside that
gym to give more than that than you
actually have
does she could have that natural talent
he has that but does he have
that stuff that valdez that's why this
is so intriguing that's why this is so
special that's why this is such
a different thing to see
he's a humble dude that comes from
humble beginnings
and understands his limitations but he
punches above his way he's like a series
is like a series don't tell me you
should call stevens a playstation 5
don't do that
don't do that
king promotion sounds good
but
season two next week hell yeah
i was watching mike tyson interview and
he's telling the story him and don king
and the boys and he got don king
for uh 60 sacks one night word
i'm picking valdez valdez
loves to telegraph his hooks
okay so
telegraph in his hooks
can you capitalize on the telegraph
cc
if uh if alaska valdez actually
telegraphs a left hook that means he's
telling from the shoulder from the leg
right
and if he's telling from the shoulder
he's he's telling from the leg and he's
moving when he throws the left hook
do you think that he probably worked on
that in camp and try to try to mask that
so you don't know if it's coming over
the top off it's going through the
bottom because if it's something innate
in the character inside his character
while he's boxing because i got certain
things that i do and um my wife will
watch me when i'm when i'm moving right
and i got certain things i do with my
feet
and you know your tails
so if if if you working on your tails
and you know how you can set somebody up
well you show your tail
and then
he goes for it and then you just
capitalize on it that way i again say
uh
shakur reminds me he looks like my son
which is crazy my youngest son dante
um
but he looks like a mockiao kid like a
like like like a kid that that likes to
mix it up so again
stevenson if you keeps if he keeps you
at his whale house his arm distance is
naughty should call stevenson
if he
allows you to if you allow him to work
the jab and then to do the straight
right at the belly
he's going to actually dominate you
and he throws the same combinations as
bud crofit because he's been trained by
bo mac as well he's been in there with
bulma working the mix
and you can see
the same things
that bud does he does but he does it
faster
he's a little he's like well cause he's
younger he's a hair faster than bud and
he throws the same jab
right hand
double left hook under the rib
that bud does
same combination
but it worked for him and he said does
the same double up stepping
that bud does i'm watching it right now
i mean you can only pick up great habits
from great fighters and i think budd is
a great fighter
if stevenson gets to win
do you think he
i think the main thing is
give his career an extra bump
um
shakira is a psp
he you stupid
he sparred with bud for this fight yeah
he spawned with bud for this fight does
he give it a bump in his career
yeah
because he'll be a two belt champion
in that division so
what you expect from him going forward
is hopefully that he goes for the third
belt
in this division that he's in right now
we have um
two fights on this undercard that i am
so interested in seeing and expecting to
see that i i think they're going to be
spectacular we have that young kid that
was in the olympics that's boxing and he
is such a loud mouth and but he backs up
his smoke so
i love him i i want to see more of him
uh i'll tell you his name in a second
because his name is we only seen him
fight twice i seen his olympic stuff i
think his last name was davis
but um he's a really he's a real good
fighter very good very sharp very fast
um
he knows how to
he's a boxer
he has some pop in him he's a boxer so
really good stuff
let me see
valdez is star filled with the todd
howard signature bugs yo you're stupid
taylor surround the fight is a war
he had keyshawn davis
yeah i was gonna watch the taylor
serrano fight but again i know they have
to end and you know i'm gonna watch that
later but uh here we go here we go
keyshawn davis versus sanchez this is a
fight that is so good um
lightweights beautiful stuff i think
he's going to be somebody to watch in
the future as far as keyshawn davis
my my my son name is keisha
dope crazy because my favorite uh
football player wide receiver keyshawn
johnson was my favorite jets player
shut up and give me the damn ball was
his book i read that book and lost my
mind i became a jet fan uh through and
through yeah so i wasn't there
with uh
everybody else with joe namas and the
fur coast you know new york city
situations i wasn't there for that but
um i got down with the shut up and give
me the ball keyshawn johnson and you
know vinnie chester verdi and the boys
quebec and all those guys
and um
where he called his own teammate a light
bulb he keyshawn johnson crazy boy wow
boy
so i'm down i'm i'm my bloody green i'm
i'm stuck i'm stuck with those dudes um
i mean they had a pretty good draft so
yeah yeah yeah
let me see let me see what's going on
over here
what does this fight do for you who i
got in the the serrano till the fight
i'm not a super mma guy i would have to
uh
uh defer to my man fawns
little known fact
uh fonz and i were supposed to be doing
a combat talk collabo where
uh you know he's the boxing rookie
and i'm the
um
mma rookie
so uh
we was both gonna educate each other
logistics happen and stuff happens so
you know um
it is what is maybe me and him might do
a combat show
uh one night you know as as this show
evolves you listen i really want you
guys to hit me in the dms uh
tag me or whatever i know y'all follow
me on twitter if you don't follow me on
twitter's kingdavidotw i mean
and just follow me on twitter and just
hit me in the dm say yo what you want to
see what you want to see to happen uh
because um i have to work on this a
whole lot better you know do you want to
overlay do you want to see like little
king in the corner you know doing though
the boxing like what what is it this one
i got to get him cleaned up though
you know um do you want to see something
like that uh do you want to see um
in the waiting screen do you want to see
a little king you know uh boxing
somebody knocking somebody out white
coming soon wait a second you know
certain stuff like that so
you know these dudes out here man you
know keyshawn looks dope um he looks
ready to work
it's nothing
better than seeing
the hunger of a young fighter
that actually uh respects his craft that
actually
feels great in doing it because he's 23
years old they're both 23 years old he's
five nine this is keyshawn davis um
uh esteban sanchez is 510. uh 136 pounds
uh both of them 106 36.2 for keyshawn
136.6
for sanchez
they both got 70 inch arm reach
so the fight is pretty much even
um keyshawn is 4-0 uh sanchez is 18-1
with 13 knockouts
so
is is is this his setup fight for him
could be a set of fightful
you know but keyshawn coulda also saw
who name was on the board and told bob i
don't care
give me him
he's available i'll take him
could it be a mistake on his part should
he be fighting people that's uh of his
same level as far as our record goes
as possible but um
oh the boy looks ready you know um
sanchez is coming up into the ring right
now he has a cowboy hat on uh he has the
blue and white he's going under the
ropes right now no frills no stills
moving around you know throwing his
hands up in there definitely looking
ready to go
this is this is a very intriguing fight
um as a promoter i'll be nervous
especially if you have a young unproven
commodity that's an olympic uh medalist
and uh keyshawn so
i i would definitely be 100 nervous in
putting keyshawn in with a guy who has
18 fights it's not
i wouldn't do that
what's going on javier
[Music]
barrique was in the house let's go let's
go come on
all right
all fights on the car have been super
bloody
oh you talking about the uh
the mma
yeah all right so
keyshawn's coming out now
he's
wearing what is that all white
oh he has he has a rapper with him so
yeah the rap is with him i don't know
who the rap is
i say i love this
part of part of the showmanship of
boxing part of the showmanship is
entertainment if you don't know how to
entertain somebody if you don't know how
to get down and then show exactly what
you're about you don't show your
personality nobody's going to know you
nobody can endear themselves to you if
you don't show yourself if
they they can either love you or hate
you right
so you're gonna have to lean into one or
the other either you're gonna have to be
the hill or you have to be the baby face
and um
you know a lot of times i play the hill
a lot of times i play the baby face i
play the baby face for eggs box
baby face all right for the playstation
dudes i'll be playing the hill
make them dudes have the aichi face to
be having the hatchy face with me
who can't stand you but sometimes you
gotta lean into the baby face so you
gotta lean into the hill and um right
now
uh keyshawn is leaning into the uh the
hill but he got his peoples there and
they turned it up with him and this is a
great event you know it's the first time
he's on a pay-per-view as a as a as a
show fight
two two you got nico and you got uh
keyshawn right now
bob has a stable
of young fighters
and that's when you're a shrewd promoter
you know exactly who to get you know
exactly who you're going to put your
money towards and who you're going to
build up
so keyshawn is in the ring he has on a
sequence um
white and and it looks like a purple
silver
sweet sequence uh sleeveless um
hoodie
and uh is that butt there that's in the
corner with him
who's in the corner who's in the corner
what i think there's bud there
i can't see cause his head is in the way
i'll tell you in a second
i could have sworn that was but that was
standing next to him because that means
well
bud was
training with shakur i don't know if
yeah i think that was bud
let me know who was able to see that if
that was bud that was standing in the
corner with uh
keyshawn davis
let me see buddy
[Music]
um okay so you said bible
canelo man what the hell you talking
about do i got bevel or canelo yeah i
think but bibble can give him a hell of
a fight but you're talking about one of
the best people that's in the game
that's on the top of his game the only
person that he lost to was floyd i don't
care what anybody says about anything
about
uh canelo i don't care
he gets the results in the ring he knows
how to throw that that that that was bud
okay
yeah that's what's up uh sp
look at that 18 and one with eight kos
that means that he's a puncher
he's a he's a boxer with a light punch
okay he has one loss
what happens if he believes in himself
tonight
that's it
as a promoter you can't be scared
you can't be scared right as a promoter
you got to believe in what you got right
so keyshawn is in the ring right now and
um keyshawn is 4-0 with three knockouts
that means only one dude surviving he
got no losses he out here
does yeah okay so yeah that is beaumac
does train them
bulmak is a budge trainer butt is in the
corner
so okay so he probably has
uh a controlling stake in his promotions
right now at the time
[Music]
that's why all that bs with these dudes
uh sooner promoters and you got buds
showing top rank and barbara talking
about the races and all this other stuff
man that's that's that's to get extra
bread
on on the re-up
oh okay so
keyshawn's uh
body looks like he he worked out pretty
well he looks like he's on a good
regimen looks he has the same form as
but a pure boxes uh or
form
sanchez looks
a little bit decent a little slim like a
slim uh uh swimmer's body
all right so the first round is getting
ready to start right now and um this is
very into this is one of the fights i
really wanted to see so keyshawn flashed
across the ring and spun
and uh do a jab
to him
he has happy feet right now so he's
moving in and out happy feet is nervous
energy
and uh
that's when you don't set your feet
you know you're moving if anybody knows
football so sanchez is trying to sleep
him with an overhand right he's trying
to keep him busy with his uh his
movement of his jab hand that is sanchez
so chances right now is backing up
keyshawn but keyshawn is jabbing and
stabbing him to the body with a jab
um to push him back off and you know he
varies the jab by going upstairs
where as you have um there's a lot of
nervous movement from sanchez uh dipping
and moving his uh his jab hand
trying to keep uh keyshawn busy keyshawn
is a little bit more relaxed he's
starting to settle in now
and uh
there we go so this is the first tie up
right now
uh sanchez threw uh right to the body
tied him up
very good um like i said there's a lot
of movement a lot of nervous energy
from sanchez
uh
he looks like a mongoose messing with a
viper
and you have keyshawn uh jabbing his way
in and pushing him forward pushing him
back
all right we have another tie up
in the center of the ring
you know it's
not not too much is being done
you know it's it's it's a nice feeling
out round
keyshawn is probably trying to learn uh
trying to implement stuff that he
learned in training cap
right now because he's not in the
olympics he's in a pro so he can take
his time
and this is a eight round fight so it's
not a 12 round or ten round fight
all right so sanchez is uh jabbing uh
throwing right hands and falling in and
holding
is a tactic uh that you do you get you
hit and if you don't know how to move
your feet fast enough you just grab
right after
so a lot of that stuff uh
that's what he's doing
let me see
nothing is being done
not as exciting as i thought
sanchez gets him a
they
job
the center of the ring uh keyshawn
tried to hit him with a left hook he's
he
not implementing
his offense like i thought he would
and it's looking eerily reminiscent of
the fight that he had with the
the japanese fighter
when he was um
in the olympics
okay
what's going on
here see this
all right
what happened to my stream
oscar valdez and shakur stevenson look
at that bottom line opponent punches
landed per round stevenson is ultimate
world class now valdez is a leak but all
right so we're back
all right so they're just um
[Music]
all right so uh canelo's just came in
canelo just walked in a room
how anybody that uh
that's down canelo
he's outside he's outside
walking with his wife all right so we
have um
now we see
keyshawn jabbing to the body he's
stabbing to the body with a nice long
jab
while sanchez is trying to get close
trying to rough him or trying to hold on
to him
trying to give him something to think
about
and
it's not a lot of work being done but oh
okay
so i see now what sanchez is trying to
do he's trying to make uh davis fall
asleep and he's trying to drop the right
hand on top if anybody uh understands
what that is there's a lonely uh
opponent to sleep
but um keyshawn has a very good defense
he keeps his hands tight to his head
and you know
sanchez isn't varying his uh jab the
nervous energy is slowing down
on sanchez
a nice jab around uh keyshawn's uh guard
keyshawn landed a right hand
straight down the pipe
oh okay davis uh nice left hook
now that left hook can end the fight if
he can land that left hook more on
sanchez
he's stabbing him to the body and he's
all right so
now keyshawn is showing a little bit
more of his offense
the the body stab with a left hook over
the top
and he finishes it with a right hook
all right cross
so yeah
so
it's pretty decent
um
sanchez is a little bit weaker than
davis is so when he tries to hold him
and push him back it doesn't go right
he said a man i'll beat canelo we yet
yeah
sanchez stop jabbing
um
he's not closing the distance and he's
just standing on outside
waiting for davis to land something so
he has to uh
establish his offense opposed to
letting davis you know throw his offense
this could go four or five rounds um
we're in the second round right now
and it's a
couple of minutes to go
yeah
it's probably a couple seconds
that's it so second round it's over
uh
not eventful
um
maybe i'm i'm expecting too much from
the kid because i saw the kid in
olympics
hopefully we can get a chance to see him
uh shine a little bit harder a little
bit harder i'm expecting a little bit
more for this kid
but again yeah
never know never know
he might uh surprise you like nico did
with the first round blast out
every every fight ain't gonna be a
knockout right
you never know
all right
so
what what's what's what's what's
what's everybody uh
prediction for the fight what rounds you
got let me see some rounds in the chat
on on uh if y'all got a knockout or who
who you got to knock out with you got
valdez you got shakur
uh you got valdez by knockout you got
your call by knockout you got valdez by
decision because she called my decision
what's going on
yes it does only take one punch sp fans
the place to
be sanchez doesn't look like he's
setting up that one punch he looks like
he's just trying to throw that one punch
from the outside and
you know throw it and pray for the best
can't
that's not a thing that's not a thing
let's see what's going on all right
okay so sanchez is actually doing some
good work i guess he listened to his
corners corner told him start pushing
him back
and sanchez is starting to step on him
now and sanchez is starting to back he's
showing up keyshawn is throwing uh
reaching jabs pouring jabs up to the top
but they're not touching
all right so that's more or less reigns
find us
and what he's doing is uh now he's
touching but sanchez is actually uh
chasing him
and trying to push him back
all right so now he just walked over him
and sanchez just went between his legs
had to be something that you had to see
it was kind of stupid that just happened
it
why you go that low is ridiculous
i hope i hope my lord just fired
tomorrow
i hope this this this fight is fire
tonight
all right be even more fire tomorrow
come on guys
let's get a little bit more on this
okay
see what i don't like what davis is
doing is he's land a punch and he'll
lean on
uh
sanchez's neck
because he doesn't know how to deal with
sanchez's offense
okay nice straight right that was on the
ear
uh sanchez uh tapped his hand told him
was behind the head
oh
okay good luck
now now davis is starting to open up but
sanchez is opening up too going back to
the body
but he's there's no sustain sustained
attack
there's a it's a hit and a falling a hit
and a falling
and that's not something that you you
know you want to do
davis is
throwing decent jabs
good
so it was a nice left foot nice right
hand
he's digging throwing right hands over
the top this might be a knockout right
here
if davis can actually capitalize on the
work that he just did see he has to stop
tying up he's too young to be tying him
he has to be able to move around and get
him off him
secured by decision
sanchez punches look
kind of tight
yeah he looked kind of tight until he
got hit with that punch
okay nervous energy pushing them back
same thing nah um
the thing with the with dave is if davis
is supposed to win right not taking
anything away from sanchez if david is
supposed to win and where we talk about
we know where we're going
who we view as the favorite who we view
as the
the add-on
so we will look at this situation and
say sanchez is the add-on and
secure is the favorite right i mean um
david's favorite
davis
has to start establishing a jab and
start putting
stringing together moments in a round
where he looks dominant in spaces
instead of holding
so the first time that sanchez goes to
hold he has to find a way to take a half
step back either back or half step to
the left or half step to the right and
he has to shoot the appropriate punches
and he has to dig to the body to to to
keep sanchez from grabbing or he has to
shoot a right over the top around the
air in order to disorient uh
uh sanchez so
he's not doing neither and i'm expecting
bulma to tell him something this this is
actually kind of telling
america because that means that the
corner is not giving him exactly what he
needs
the adjustments that he needs this this
is actually tell us on the inside and
the bow mac is expecting
but just to
understand
what
oh
that was a good that was good when
sanchez landed a good uppercut the last
round and showing the replay
sneak right past me i didn't see it
very good so far so we're in the
the
[Music]
there's a lot of swinging and missing
boring fighters
they're talking to bud right now
talking about what davis is doing and um
how does he see uh davis moving in the
ring
all right okay so davis hit uh sanchez
with some good shots
good body good right hand that's what
see there we go
good left hook all right there we go
all right so davis is actually putting c
but he falls right back into the holding
that's what you cannot do he put
together a good
space of the fight and he has to stay
with that keep him off back up slide out
throw the hook
and he's not doing it he's not doing
exactly what he's supposed to do to end
the fight earlier
you know whereas nico knew he was
setting up the right hand with the uh
because he was going around looping he
jabbed it in first he didn't want to
nico
and you know what
you have to respect the fact that niko's
fighting sanchez who has 18 fights niko
has four fights so
again i think niko probably took this
knowing that he's going to learn
something from this fight
more so than he would have not learned
anything about fighting somebody else
who was like five you know
we got 40 people in here 61 likes that's
what's up good looking
that was a crazy fight the serrano fight
is exactly what we saw
yeah yeah i i train every time i go to
the gym um
i'll be training on my oldest son and my
youngest son yeah yeah
training breaks your heart man you know
okay so there we go all right so all
right so he's actually davis actually
did exactly what i said he took a half
step uh to the right and he threw a left
to the body to dig him over and he shot
it right over the top and it's exactly
what you're supposed to do but he did it
too late in the round when he did it did
it right there he just landed her right
hand over the top as the bell sunk um
those things is supposed to be told
while they're in the corner and those
things i if if i'm training you
immediately when you get out into the
ring that's exactly what i want to see
thank you man uh okay that's that's
exactly what i want to see if i tell you
something that's exactly what i want to
see so
that stuff breaks your heart like if
you're training somebody
you know you're seeing them grow inside
the gym you're seeing certain things
that they do and if they go out there
and they get a chance to uh
fight somebody that's actually uh better
than them
that breaks your heart you're sitting
there trying to give them some type of
uh
ways to beat them and if they're not
physically equipped or mentally equipped
to beat the person that's in front of
them that's kind of heartbreaking so i
don't think i want to deal with some
heartbreak
like that train to somebody you know i
would train my kids to be into shape and
know how to defend myself but i wouldn't
train my kids to actually uh
compete
but if they was there i'll cheer them on
because you know who you gotta be if you
if if you're the trainer right you have
to be that person that throws in that
towel that means you have to witness the
beating
i couldn't do that
just let me be the parent on the outside
yo that's my baby
oh
oh
all right so
what what what what's your call i mean
she called what davis was doing right
there was he was throwing left hooks by
left hooks
on really tight really close uh davis is
now um trying to push back uh sanchez
and sanchez
it's it's eating the shots and standing
there willing to to trade with him
in the pocket
davis is actually showing some form of
offense and so is
sanchez
sanchez
is throwing right hands over the top
trying to catch davis with the same
right hands davis is showing a very
amount of punches with the left hooks
and the right hands
so um he's hitting him with left hooks
david says and he has sanchez a little
wobbly right now sanchez went to the
body he went to immediate hold
right and um davis now is trying to turn
off
half step over and he shoots the left
hook
two to the body oh he broken him he's
breaking him oh my god the fight is
going to be stopped he's breaking him
davis is hitting him with left and right
up
to the top to the side of his head
sanchez wisely holds
wisely holds i would have took a knee
uh sanchez is still there he goes right
back to the body he hits davis with an
uppercut in the middle of the ring davis
uh turtles up puts both hands on in
front of him and pushes sanchez back
sanchez
goes right back to davis's body
um
but uh davis throws a right hand and a
left hook his left hook seems pretty
pretty strong and is the left to the
body with the right hand and uppercut
sanchez is still fighting taking shots
uh davis is pounding on his chest like a
lowland gorilla and he's going for the
kill
uh this is absolutely nuts um see this
is the part where if i'm the trainer i
would have threw the towel in on sanchez
uh because sanchez is eating shots that
he doesn't need to eat
but um davis is doing weird things with
his legs uh mocking him
davis is uh definitely
trying to win
um
but uh sanchez is doing veteran things
as holding throwing and going straight
to the body
and not giving davis an opening to
finish him off
pause
that round was uh davis's best round uh
he threw everything but the kitchen sink
got the kid uh he hit him with ups
uppercuts left rights
uh
backed him up against the ropes
and imposed his will like i said he beat
his chest like a lowland gorilla while
he was in between punches he did some
wobbly stuff with his legs mocking him
and that was absolutely
great i wish he would have turned the
limit to punches and knocked him out and
then he did all of that after the fact
right
okay
i should have sinned on
yeah yeah
oh that's what's up that's right have
your son with you watching all the time
hell yeah
all right so it started off with the
left hook
and then and and sanchez is not looking
right man
[Music]
so david's in the middle ring trying to
intimidate him
oh
sanchez said the hell would it you know
what sanchez said if i'm gonna go out
i'm gonna go out
dead and dying and you you won't have to
kill me so sanchez is swinging with
reckless abandon
so and davis uh tried to return the
favor with a short left hook i think his
left hooks is really really good
to be honest with you i think he throws
a tight left hook and a nice overhand
right so check left foot he needs to
throw more check left so i think
he he's with the wrong trainer to teach
him uh check left hooks he needs to go
to mayweather camp yeah um
sanchez is trying
but he's just a step behind a step too
slow when it comes to davis's punches
davis's punches varies
he throws uppercuts left hooks right
hands
all in the timely fashion all right and
in the jet
davis is all abandoned the jab right he
he puts it out there as a touch
and he's too busy with the left hook he
hit uh sanchez with four left hooks in a
row
um
and he went to the body
and the head he's going right back to
the head with the right hand
now in the left hook the left hook
he's trying to pull with his left jab
and sanchez is in the middle of the ring
he's still game
he's still throwing punches
and davis is still
trying to you know knock him out
very this is this is like a one-way
beating
whereas one guy looks punk drunk punch
drunk which is sanchez and davis is
looking for the combination that can
take him out of there
which i say would probably be an
uppercut but
sanchez is still throwing he threw five
shots and bounced it off of davis and
sanchez is still fighting salute salute
this man salute
the fact that he's behind and he's given
100
i respect this man i respect everything
that sanchez is doing he's in a fight
that he is losing and he gets hurt every
so often which davis just hit him with a
left hook just drove him back to the
ropes and davis is ripping rights to the
body and uppercuts up through uh to the
head he just hit him with a left hook
uh and he's up against the rope uh
sanchez is taking a hell of a beating
and the referee stops the fight the
referee stops the fight total respect
total respect for davis taking a fighter
that had 18 fights under his belt
uh
total respect for sanchez standing there
giving as good as he got uh but again
you know he stood in there a little bit
too long he got a cut ripped on his eye
davis put in that work
you know bulma got a win tonight with
his fighter
i think beaumac needs to train him a
little bit differently but i mean that
that stuff could have came a whole lot
earlier lose the showboat and stick to
exactly what you want and actually learn
how to check left hook
that fight could have been over a long
time ago
[Music]
are you stupid
[Music]
yeah you know sometimes you're not going
to get trainers that's going to stop the
fights you know you just won't
to be honest with you sometimes you're
going to get trainers that's going to
actually believe in the fighter
sanchez was given as much as he can get
in that round he just wasn't the same
level of fighter he wasn't the same
caliber fighter
so
he's okay so
if anybody's looking at
davis his left hooks is arm shots you
see
that's why he's not knocking him out
that's the same exact thing that buzz
does
those are arm shots
okay he's not
putting his hip in the shot he's not
putting his waist in the shot if he is
putting his hip and his waist in the
shot sanchez will not stand
all right so
when you throw arm shots you throw arm
shots because you don't want to overly
commit yourself because you're afraid of
the return
that's why those are arm shots there
he he knows how to throw a proper shot
those are arm shots
shoulder a little bit here so he's
throwing from here and he's thrown from
here and he's
expecting
not to get any return because if
something does come back he can roll
back and get out of there you
ladies
know
gentlemen here very good
very good
fifth fight
we got two more fights to go right
two more fights together
[Music]
two more fights or one more
fight after being sick
let me see
the olympic silver medalist who stepped
up to eight round status
didn't get past six
who says i want to move as fast as i can
okay so he wants to fight
you know all the other champions
at a young age i hear that
so right now or we're expecting we're
expecting
um
[Music]
him to at least fight for a championship
and then within his next four or five
fights right
so
he um
he he needs to
um
learn a little bit more on how to
deliver
checklist folks
get out of somebody actually holding
them
so he can actually uh fight harder
and don't let his back touch the ropes a
lot of things that i saw
he should have never let his back touch
the ropes
he should have kept everything in the
center of the ring
uh check left hooks uh learn how to hook
off your jab he knows how to hook up the
jab but he's not doing hooking off of
his jab
he's hooking straight up
but see it's he they showed him throw he
landed full clean left foot
it's
if if he actually put his hip behind his
left hook and turn that leg and throwing
it and actually committed and ripped it
sanchez would have been out there a
whole lot sooner so
i mean but come on
you can't deny the results right
but remember winning masses deficiencies
and those deficiencies is the
deficiencies that come back and haunt
you because if somebody can capitalize
on your deficiencies
then again what happened
right he's gonna definitely fight
somebody next yeah
he he got us some good work he'll be
fighting probably again in august
if not yeah august what we're in uh
april may june july august probably july
he'll be fighting again in probably july
i would have him fighting again at the
end of june
if i was his promoter all right so they
got she called stevens
in the background and looking at it
right now he has the gloves on
the fact that he has his gloves on right
now that bowls well for everything
all right
but he's not doing any mitt work uh any
warm work so
he should be getting some more work done
in a minute
the main event is next
okay so if the main event is next um
because you're going to see a fighter
valdez that actually puts that hip
inside that shot that actually throws
that that that check left hook
so
i i gotta go shakur
in the world today but i'm not i'm not
ignorant to the fact that
valdez
out of the two somebody put a little bit
of salt pepper on him he's a little bit
more seasoned than the boy so
i don't know
alvarez
tango earl smith's
for the last one you put yourself in
number one
i don't know man
i don't know man it's it's it's gonna be
a bomb burner but i'm gonna have to go
with shaco for a knife round tko you see
me
i feel like that makes me and he throws
nice shots you know she killed throws
nice shots and
i gotta stick with the north the boy
from the north
north stand up new york stand up
jersey stand up he from brick city come
on man you know brick city
i can't can't disrespect gotta ride with
the brick city boy
gotta ride with that brick city boy
he wears hat to the side too man like
the old 80s kid like i don't know who
his pops is it's crazy
but he wears hat to the side
but um
valdez got that little man he got that
he has the heart of a fighter
that's the first thing that you want
when your fighter comes in the ring and
it comes in the gym you in the gym you
got that heart you
when i'm in the gym
that gym is my gym
right
and and you gotta you walk around that
gym like that gym is your gym like you
the baddest dude in the land
you give a shout out to my son he was
there
when i was uh hitting the heavy bag and
they had this heavyweight that was that
was managed by uh don king
i haven't seen him i think he probably
lost the a fighter well he was managed
by don king
and uh he came in and i'm working on the
heavy bag and he wanted to work on the
bag that i'm working on
it's not good that's not how it gonna
work it's not gonna work like the way
that but let me tell you something
i'll spar you
i don't care if you going prone care if
you you pro what about
i'll put that work on you i'll i'll ruin
you
so i went and just you know he was on
one end of the back and i'm on the other
end of the back but my mentality is my
mentality is when i'm hitting the back
i'm in the back like i'm fighting you
so if you throw right hand i'm catching
i'm pivoting and i'm hitting i'm jabbing
i'm stabbing i'm hitting and i'm moving
i'm working the back i'm working the bag
like i'm fighting him he's working the
bag like he's fighting me my son is
sitting there witnessing all of this
stuff
and my son is sitting like oh my god he
like i guess he never saw me get the dog
got the dog come out and um
after after i think we did this for four
or five rounds
and this training came to me i was like
man that's the best work my my boy got
all all all training camp um and we
didn't even spawn and i would i would
have loved to spar with him i would love
to spawn with all i would have loved to
put hands on the balls
but um nah man
it's it's it's fantastic stuff you gotta
you gotta have that walk you out of
feeling the heart of the champion and i
believe valdez has that heart of the
champion i believe valdez has to be
dragged out of there
his pedigree
his team that he runs with
is canelo
nobody can ever say that canelo don't
have the heart of the champion so
that's his team that's the squad oh
they're coming out right now fight get
ready go you right you right
who called it who said it was next
who call it
stevenson
he said he better have bricks in his
fists ah
who that c-max said the fight is next
right
35 people stand up the canelo nickadella
oh the lights is out
let's go let's go
there we go there we go
[Music]
i gotta respect that kid man
this this is gonna be this is this is
this is one of those fights i i'm be
honest with you i don't think valdez
wanted this fight
i think valdez wanted to you know take
another fight or whatever whatever
and uh
he had he had no options
but to take this fight and and and to to
get in there with stevenson
i know stephenson wanted the fight
but didn't your mama ever tell you be
careful what you wish for
be careful don't don't call the devil
for the devil hear you the devil show up
what you gotta do with you the devil pop
up in that room after you don't call
them man
devin haney out there he fighting cam
bosses that's gonna be a good fight for
us boy because i'm gonna tell you right
now
going into that fight right now if you
had me pick right now you told me take
my money and throw it down on the table
i'm gonna have to give my money to
cambodia's right now i don't know man
it's kind of
canelo will controversy his seat
alongside raiders owner mark davis and
top-ranked hall of fame promoter bob
league
ladies
ladies and gentlemen before we walk the
champions league the only dude at the
entrance
oh what up italian cows coming too got
to support the king
glad i could watch it live all hell the
king blessings italian clowns with the
10 super chat
that's my dude
so yo main event about to start
these dudes about to get it popping
they got uh some old dude that's uh
singing the mexican anthem and you gotta
respect that
uh um
i love the fact that you know each
nationality people don't know the whole
ramifications about fights and
what the gods and stuff used to do he
used to bring their champions and they
had each god had they fight song and the
song ring out and then they championed
it come on they champions to fight for
their gods and stuff that's how you get
mount olympus and these dudes training
for the olympics and all that other
stuff it's a whole stuff that trickled
down this stuff is bread in us this
stuff is inside of us everybody has a
fighter with inside their body
so
um
it's dope to see
people that get a chance to dedicate
their self to the craft to
get that out of them to get that warrior
spirit out of them and i believe
everybody has a warrior spirit within
them
you know tonight we're gonna see these
two dudes with their warrior spirit
displayed
then that's something that i i i can't
uh
yeah i think i'm gonna be like a 90 year
old dude
that only gets up for saturdays to watch
the fights
dope stuff man this is
i don't know man i can never lose it i
can
always watch that stuff but
i'm telling you
it's this
the the reason why
this fight is so intriguing
is the intangibles the what-ifs
the questions right
what if what if um
[Music]
valdez can take
shakur's power
what if valdez tags secure
like you know um now the american anthem
is being sung you know
there's there's questions that's gonna
be answered in this fight at least we
hope they're gonna be answered in this
fight
and
there's there's nobody
in your entourage that can help you
shout out to hollywood's what's going on
all right two dollar super chat keep it
up king love to work you putting in
thank you brother
100 i'm gonna try my best
that's all you can do right
i tell everybody follow the passion
follow the dream put their heart out
they don't care how old you are i don't
care what the circumstances is
put one foot in front of the other
there's always going to be some form of
of adversity but you you got to push
dope man
push through
but um
your corner can't fight for you
the trainer can't fight for you
the only person that can fight for you
is you like you can't nobody else can
train for you but you
so this is all incumbents upon the
fighter they can give you advice they
can give you guidance they can give you
help
if you're willing to take that help
nobody can take those punches for you
so
man oh man this is this is
mono-e-mano this is this is the the tip
of the spare this is where
the rubber meets the road this is it
right here
these dudes is getting ready to come out
they get ready to show exactly what they
got so all that talking all the way up
to this
now now now
you gotta back up all that whatever you
said
so you know valdez wasn't really saying
nothing
yeah
he's doing this shakur was doing a whole
lot of talking
one thing just go go around beating no
women allegedly whatever that means
um
so we out here now
so i think uh
i think secure coming out first
let me see
that's right this is where boys become
men
javier
at 90 facts my brother that's right
what type of mentality does that that
tell you man i just heard shakira say
that oscar valdez has a don't lay down
mentality
what happens when you when you're in the
ring with somebody that puts his lunch
pail in the middle of the ring and says
let's go
my mother my mom's my girlfriend my wife
made my meal
we're gonna fight and i'm gonna eat my
lunch and i'm continuing to fight
what happens when that dude brings his
lunch bail and then he's ready to work
that's that's
what you have to action so what really
happens then where are you at with it
then
man oh man
this is a different this is the
different fighter in this fight i mean
he fought harry the last time heron's a
good fighter i'm not saying anything i'm
not taking anything away from him but
here is not no valve
[Music]
you know so
really what's going next after this
commercial
you know because they got they got paid
commercials and stuff
that we have to
[Music]
electrolytes
at some point in time let me see what's
going on hey king how do you feel about
the just draft
cake and picks a cheesy crunch try pure
protein snacks oh you know every year i
feel good about the draft picks
and every year i feel disappointed about
this season
how many times must you be beaten by the
same same
sticks
chewie
i don't know man i'm just a a
a beaten down fan
that won a good season i just want a
playoff season
i want a season where they get to the
playoffs right
that's that's all i want i'm not asking
for too much let's just please get to
the playoffs but
please that's it
i don't need you to be tom brady
i don't need i don't know zach i don't
need you to be
uh
any i just i just need you to guide the
team and
just get us to the playoffs that's it
just
do that
and then i'll be happy so i think the
draft picks are solid
but then i guess what
we have to see what they what they pan
out to be right they get to new york
they have a couple of cheesecakes and
stuff like that and then these dudes be
feeling these stuff and then we don't
get the product that we just promised so
i don't know new york air change dude
sometimes you got to be about this air
if you're not about this air new york
city if you're not about this scrutiny
if you're not about these fans about
putting that work on your neck these
these years that we've been suffering
don't come here man stay there stay the
hell away if you can't deal with new
york pressure get up out of here
he said like sony
it runs on advanced lithium battery
technology
and it's just as powerful yeah
mma is definitely the same thing
[Music]
that's not growing
no no i didn't i didn't i didn't what up
fuzzy bell over there i didn't skip
anything you know um i got the zone um i
can watch all those fights later i got i
have all my streaming packages here i
can watch all those fights later but
when when you're preparing to to watch a
fight you have to mentally get yourself
prepared to watch
uh a situation um if i'm doing a stream
i would have did a stream about them and
then we could have talked about them but
um
one night i might do mma slash boxing
night and then i switch over from the
mma card and get to the boxing car but
it was some boxing cards that i was
stuff that i want to see i wanted to see
uh keyshawn davis i wanted to see nico
so um sometimes you have to
let some of these uh established
fighters go
and i can watch that fight later because
that's not something i'm doing combat
talk on
um for to build this up because
when any of y'all see me y'all be like
yo remember the time we watch nico
knocked the dude out in the first round
yo king that was crazy right
yeah so we have that history together so
we can talk about that stuff oh remember
when davis was fighting sanchez and he
was telling he had to stop he had the
hook he had to dig in
yeah so
we had to talk we had that together so i
have to pick it sometimes and you know
i thought the shaquille stevenson i
thought the fact that they both
uh
have no um
valdez has no stevenson has no uh
they're coming out right now
um
they both got belts
unification about
this is the year the unifications baby
let's make it happen man
everybody
new york city is rocking right now
you got people all outside without the
mask on
i thought i'll never see that
[Music]
but we back we back at it
[Music]
and stevenson
fighters love fighters there is nate
diaz
he came in a little earlier
speaking of fighters
is out there
his uh jamal haring
uh
look who he's sitting next he's sitting
next to barbara
yo
you dudes
better respect
bob aaron [ __ ] winky right they go butt
bud is 35 years old and he's fighting
he's going to fight errol spence as soon
as that contract gets signed and harold
spence is younger than
him i mean but that car crashed man it
made him 90 years old boy
put me in the car crash i'm 106 tomorrow
all right so valdez is coming out first
that's crazy it must have been a flip of
a coin because valdez uh name
is on the billing as number one
so it must have been okay your name is
on the on the billing is number one but
i'll come out second i mean sometimes
dudes just on the a-side
they be doing some diva stuff man
i don't know
[Music]
to make a spaces because i
i was wearing coach i'm gonna wear a
coat tomorrow
30 days of coats ain't over remember we
went to pax baby
i'm doing dope buddha what's up baby boo
this in the house y'all my man buddha
pulled up
yo
what up buddha
you need to sleep
buzzing from the fight though have a
great fight folks that's what's up
brother thank you for showing up
my man buddha buddha from destiny
buddha time crazy that's what i do yo
you know what i respect buddhist so much
man
buddha was like yo man playing destiny
ain't playing with the clan how much
you're playing with my boy
yo king man you mind if i go and i leave
the clan and i joined my man clan i saw
a lot of hell out of you buddha
of course man i'll be like a motel six
man i keep the light on for buddha all
day man
oh man that ex that that that listen
listen
a little little known fact king is
trying to get out to
to cali to be out there at that uh event
man
if xbox hits me up man
the boy might be gone
but it would only be for two days
it would be uh the day that you get
there the day of the show and i'll leave
that night
because then you don't need to be
running around e3 because it ain't no e3
so it could just be
literally whatever they have there that
day i will probably fly in go to a date
and then fly out if uh if me be if it is
what it is
that event is june 12th
june 12th
remember
xbox owns june
so
secure came up to the ring he didn't
waste any time
all right so
huge mexican contingent
and
is out here
for valdez but security come on man why
jersey did come across the bridge better
show out for this kid man
this is crazy who i got i got shakur by
ninth round uh tko stoppage
i think that uh valdez is going to want
to continue but i think he won't be able
to continue
but yo
i've been wrong plenty of times in the
past
so you got blood in the corner holding
shakur's belt
so
bud had one fighter that actually
won tonight that was keyshawn davis
so
here we go
two
panthers
on the chest
iron lord
podcast on the chest
boxing feeling good let's go let's go
you like she cool a lot
yeah
me too me too executive director
[Music]
i would have kept my hair cut a little
bit lower though
i don't know man i'm a weirdo
keep my hair cut a little bit lower you
can get the joke come on stop playing
with me
kept my head cut a little bit lower
haircut low stop playing with me
[Music]
we got a good night of fights
[Music]
i love it it's juego
ah
but my faith
and now you should know tyson
my man
oh bud's your favorite that's what's up
just pull up on me when he fights
when he fights my favorite and errol
spence pull up on me
uh tyson is is
a dope fighter
he's he's done a lot of good things
outside the ring that i really i'm
really vibe with
raising that money for that kid that
needs a heart transplant
that's that's a real special dude man
total respect he gave deontay wilder so
much respect on his retirement please
let deontay wild to fight for the
championship
blue moon fc here we go that's right
i'll be here brother believe that that's
right man we'll be here together man
we'll be here together ten toes down in
the dirt are standing here making sure
that we put his work for these fights on
god let's go
here we go show those teeth
ain't nothing like a young kid being
strong enough to get up in that ring and
fight boy
okay
so he came in first then down to him
first
okay so i see how they was doing that
they was playing both ends of the cards
but
bob aaron was dope
okay
newark new jersey's in the house brick
cities in the house stand up put your
hands up
let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
well there's in the building boy boys
canelo out who bring canelo out
who'll bring canelo out you gotta you
got it
this is mono man who bring canelo out
have a blessed night thank you clowns
heading to bed gotta watch the rest
tomorrow god bless i feel you bro thank
you so much for showing up man
you know i'm a night owl my night just
begun
it's only just begun
let's go
i'ma tell you right now
oh boy look like an aztec warrior boy
i don't know
may the best man win
may the best man win
both got perfect records baby both
walking over the delicious somebody
going home with feces in their socks
you look like a young julio caesar
chavez what the
hell anybody had a chance to watch
julius caesar service on the come up boy
that i swear to god
oh my god they got my man out there the
referee is dope
yo yo let's go
everybody is about this smoke let's go
all right all right all right gotta call
a fight all right set tonight in the
fight
yeah i could do that voice too what up
looks beautiful
looks beautiful
ain't nothing like a sellout crowd with
the lights crack and lack and the world
is backing you
here we go
[Music]
all right so they're both in the middle
of the ring
you can see the size difference
and secure is looking taller
but um
valdez is
stalking stepping in on him shakur is
actually jabbing
to keep him out trying to control him
with his jab and shooting the right hand
over the top
and uh
valdez goes underneath with a left hook
while trying to stay out of the range of
the the jab from secure
still in the middle of the ring kid
doing the range find a jab
oh and uh
he hit him with a right hand he hit a
valdez with a right hand right about
this
swung wildly in this
again
and uh he's jabbing shooting the left
hand
so
all right valdez again does the same
wild
uh tripping up over his feet and i guess
it's because he uh doesn't know uh how
to fight herself for it makes no sense
to me
but um again
he's back at him again
back in the middle of the ring and he's
stalking
trying to get him to the middle of the
ring
all right so again
we have uh
valdez trying to get chica up against
the ropes so he can square him up
so he can look like a regular fighter
all right so they clenched up right now
they're touching you can see this is
high speed chest right here
uh guys all right so valdez is uh
varying his height
and his levels while secure is uh
tagging him to the body and reaching
with his range find the jab
all right so
again
is continuing to
keep his jab uh in his face in valdez's
oscar
you know is uh moving
and dipping under
because stepping on him now like i told
you i figured that he would
uh and he's uh trying to dig under the
rib
so again jacob is continuing with the
jab and he's throwing the left over
all right so again this is what i'm
talking about where you continue to keep
your spots open
in the fight uh sakia is controlling the
fight
and his jab but valdez caught him
with a nice left hook for a ticket well
and he has valdez back to the rope out
there circles to the middle of the ring
and the round is over
very good work if i was to give that
round to anybody i would have to give
that round to stevenson stevenson did a
little bit more of the work by keeping
his range finder in his face as well
it's his right hand
which is his jab and he's shooting the
straight left to either to the body or
bring it around uh to a cross to his
face
very good stuff um valdez looked a
little bit off
in the middle of that round
yeah yeah shaquille of power punches is
moving him back but
valdez is doing a little too much yeah
and this is true
uh
we're both watching the same things and
that's nervous energy
right so you said you figured by the
fourth round that's when they settle
down they actually get into the fight
when they settle down
i
honestly think uh valdez
in that first round was expecting a lot
more from chicago
i think he's going back processing it in
the second round to come out and show a
little bit more so now they're in the
middle of the ring round two started
so um
now valdez is calming down a little bit
more
but he can't allow keep allowing
uh chico to throw these jabs these
range-finding jabs out there
and
see
sakura throws a left
a right hand over
uh
after he throws the jab he throws his
right hand hook over the jab
and he's now he's setting up uppercuts
because valdez is just leaning in
forward
all right so
valdez is trying to figure out the
puzzle
and she keeps trying turning his uh
valdez's back towards the rope
he's controlling the distance
he's controlling the ring
he's controlling valdez
um
to the hook
check hook and he's throwing strong
punches to the body valdez is uh trying
to catch him pitch
and right now valdez
is trying to get close to chicago
trying to start landing some punches
there it is
see
there it is it's uh
secure is continuing to land the jab
right hand i mean um
left hand
and the left hand is the one that's
doing the most of the bulk of the jab uh
damage on valdez without the okay now so
valdez that a call against the ropes
secure
spun off and grabbed
so the goal is not to let valdez uh get
uh stevenson against the ropes
and to actually pivot off the ropes
anytime stevenson does get him on the
ropes but sequoia keeps landing
the straight left
down the pipe
and uh
valdez is throwing punches in bunches
right now hitting shaquille to the body
hitting his elbows
and he's pushing him to the ropes now
now valdez is showing some life
yes
he's going straight and he's uh
definitely giving stevenson something to
look out for while this is working now
about this most productive half of the
round
uh stevenson is sitting there
trying to figure out what valdez is
doing next while this is going old
school chavez
like i figured that he would
and
he hit stevenson
with a straight right
very very good round for both i still
give stevenson this round
um because he was busy in the middle of
the round he's busy in the beginning of
the round uh you say valdez
brought it up at the end of the round
but what valdez notices now is that he
has to abandon going to uh stevenson's
head and to just target his body target
his elbows target anything that he can
hit that he can break so whatever he
land on he must break let me see what's
going on too old support that's
definitely true
i can't love you brother but this is too
old
to put my head out that's what's up
brother god bless see you soon
valdez is very intense in the corner
listening to eddie reynoso very
intensely
um
round is about to start
they're putting the mouthpieces in
they're coming out now
you got to give it to him
hopefully he puts implements what eddie
vanessa wants done
he's in the middle of the ring
uh valdez is and he's going to uh
stephenson stevenson is meeting him with
a range find the jab just touching
valdez's gloves to shoot
the left under the body or over the top
very good all right so now valdez is
jabbing and he's getting secured to the
rope secure circling and around
and again
valdez is trying
to the body he's trying to hit anything
that he can get his hands on
this round he's actually pushing
stevenson back some
and then back okay
so valdez is actually landing a straight
right and he's going under mike tyson's
style under
uh
stevenson's jab stevenson's back to
rangefinding and stevenson wants a
little bit of get back by going to the
body
do we get a chance to see
the warrior heart of stevenson
that's right oh beautiful uh
right hand uh off the break
[Music]
from uh
stevenson stevenson is throwing a left
to the body
very good remember he's in the southpaw
stance so he's uh touching touching the
guard of valdez and
uh he's trying to set valdez up to see
if there's any holes involved in the
guard
and valdez keeps throwing it straight
right to and he moves shakur stevenson's
head back every time he does so so
now valdez is getting the respect of
stevenson by pushing him back to the
ropes and he's shooting straight right
hand down the pipe
this is definitely
uh turning into something that we wanted
to see
valdez is landing shakur's landing
um they're back into the middle of the
ring
who gets the chance to work this
strategy off valdez is hunting
right now and he's shooting right hands
out of the pop-up stance
uh he's he's chasing them stevenson is
falling back
uh again valdez is chasing them
stevenson turned them
this is definitely
what we expected to see
stevenson has valdez up against the
ropes rangefinding got this fun back to
the middle of the ring
and now
uh stevenson's back is towards the ropes
and valdez is
stalking him
right hand left foot by valdez
[Music]
and he taps his gloves well does
stevenson hit some low about this looks
at him like come on man those are the
jewels i need those for later
and the round is over
[Music]
i will give that round to valdez i will
give this to the one
while this did the most all right so all
we we we in agreement right now
yeah mike was a destroyer of men valdez
did wake up
with historic architecture yeah yeah
well he is controlling the space but
i i think we both got all of us got it
right right now so far i think it's two
to one right
um what was valdez doing that was
different
he started landing that straight right
hand out of the pop-up stance so he'll
swing on the swing on the swing on the
pop-up and you shoot the right hand and
stevenson's face is right there
stevenson got confused by it because he
did it a couple of times in a row
all right so
round four starting right now let's go
what up
all right so again so valdez comes
across the ring again stevenson throws
his jab valdez is uh not in the pop-up
stance he's shooting the right hand and
he's trying to time him with the left he
wants to get him with that left but he's
he's crisscrossing him
he's crisscrossing him he's
crisscrossing him and what i'm telling
he's crisscrossing he's walking him down
all right um but secure is actually
throwing the jab and shooting the the
left over the top he's remember he's in
the southpaw stance so he's not throwing
a uh left-hand jab he's throwing a
right-handed jab and shooting the left
down the pipe and he's digging valdez to
the body valdez is still in the center
of the ring
busy hand movements looking like a young
uh julio cesar chavez valdez is
and
here we go again back to the middle of
the ring same business secure stevenson
controlling distance
uh
you got a jab you got a left hand
and a cross
and he's bringing it up the middle
so
again so what what i would tell
um
about this to do is
uh throw straight right hands uh throw
the double ups two straight right hands
and then hook off of the left when he
gets the chance to touch the second uh
uh right hand that's what i would tell
them to do going into this uh
this round here but again
he did it he did exactly what i said
double right hand and he hooked off of
exactly he has she corners in the corner
and he's landing hella shots
that's exactly what i told him that i
would have told him to do
shoot the double right hand and when he
gets them up against the ropes soon as
the the second right hand lands you
throw the left under the body
um
it works all the time that's something
that you're supposed to do to southpaws
again so
valdez is back in the middle of the ring
um
that he's he's being pushed up to the
back of the ropes now and shakur is
stabbing him uh to the body with the jab
and coming over the top with
the right hand he's
he's throwing three four shots valdez is
eating these shots
i don't think that he should um because
the perception of the round being lost
is here
so again he has to push
push he's pushing
he's pushing there we go he's going
after sugar he's getting shakur against
the ropes i think this is the only fight
that uh valdez can win is by roughing
shakur up
uh because if he allows uh stevenson to
dictate the the jabbing uh in the
stabbing with the left
that's not a fight that he won
absolutely
disgusting no
this is a fantastic chess match high
speed chest i say after the fifth round
the fight will definitely open up
another round to stevenson stevenson is
winning three rounds to one in my
opinion
the determination and the focus that it
takes
that that round stevenson let that round
slip away you shoulda you should have
worked harder in that round
you have to really dig down
use that
determination never give up
this is definitely crazy
attic is up late you're not playing no
more well elder ring is over fatty attic
is playing some other stuff
um at the moment
elder ring is still popping with the
king
i made it to one farm and spot that i
see this is very
dope for me and and i get at least uh
at least 10 million to 15 million uh
uh runes
in an hour probably make like 50 million
rooms in an hour
so some stuff that i'm doing live in the
moment
yeah i can see why they have zero losses
those both
high speed chests both of them
all right so they back at it again so
valdez is shooting the street right
and he oh he's going straight to his
body
all right so
all right so now
you have valdez
um in the middle of the ring with
stevenson where he doesn't want to be
because he has he's had a complete
deficit in the center of the ring with
stevenson
stevenson's controlling it uh with the
jab and he's trying to go all around the
guard
like nico did earlier today uh with the
straight right hand
i mean straight left hand
all right but valdez is popping
stevenson with his straight right hand
all right and
he's uh moving in moving in
he's hunting he's hunting
and valdez is continuing to pop out and
go to his body so okay so we see that uh
stevenson
uh is having a problem when
um valdez gets him to the ropes now we
this is the questions that we ask can uh
stevenson handles while there's punch
can he handle valdez's pressure
and
can about this handle stevenson's boxing
power
this is the stuff that we wanted to see
this is the stuff that we're saying
they're back in the center of the ring
where shakur is actually controlling
distance and valdez is now turtling up
and he's trying to get to
stevenson valdez is
and he's shooting the right hand
going at him stevenson has made the
adjustment
when valdez shoots the right hand he
turtles up and he steps over to his left
which is his dominant hand
this is right
he's throwing the uppercuts and he's
shooting the left right
nice combinations from stevenson
stevenson is holding on the top of
valdez head got worn by the referee
all right so valdez is again stalking
and going to stevenson's body any time
he gets close to stevenson he goes
straight to his body he hits him to the
body four or five times
and that is a fantastic thing from
valdez because uh in the center of the
ring
it belongs to stevenson
beautiful left hand from stevenson
straight down the pike and
valdez ate it he could be a little bit
punch drunk right now um but he has a
hell of a poker face right now
but valdez is eating right hand
stevenson is throwing them
round is over
again stevenson gets another round and
he gets that round over that left hand
that he threw straight down the pipe
which was absolutely crazy 4-1 hell yeah
it's it's it's not a close fight at all
if you're watching it to be honest with
you i mean it's a tight fight as far as
skills go but um i give it so far four
to one um
that whole sequence at the end
when soon as he hit him with that
straight uh left
and then he repeatedly hit him with a
couple of left he stole that round in my
opinion uh from steve uh stevenson did
from valdez
yeah middle of the ring is key for
stevenson try pure protein snacks no
liberty mutual customizes yeah
he said who did that for you
the corner is key for valdez if he
listens and even also can only do
exactly what what um
he he possibly can
alright so stevenson is in the middle of
the ring trying to get to valdez because
he believes he has valdez ready to go
valdez forgot his mouthpiece on purpose
so again
they forgot the mouthpiece and and
valdez gave him albert about this
sometimes about this is circling around
the referee and now they're in the
middle of the ring right now so
right back at it this is round number
six
got 12 rounds to go
i actually there you go
oh my god oh so stevenson just dropped
valdez drow valdez swung with a wild
left hook while uh stevenson hit him
with uh uppercut and he dropped him
beautiful knock down
stevenson is going with the strong right
hand i mean uh yeah strong right hand
i mean strong left hand to drop valdez
he's doing uppercuts
right hands over the top
he's uh
attacking valdez
and a man of valdez is tapping his
gloves
and stevenson is showing his power
stevenson threw a left hook
valdez hit him
coming in
well this is still there even though he
does look like a sitting duck
and stevenson looks like he's picking
them apart with uh jabs and straight
left hooks
valdez is getting a little bit desperate
throwing shots
while stevenson is shooting up the
middle and stepping over to his right
circling him to his
his power hand
and valdez is continuing to throw shots
so it may be darkest before the storm
but valdez is still there to throw
straight right hands
while stevenson is throwing the one two
and going straight towards valdez this
is fighting at its finest this is high
speeds chest this is modeling this is
when you got to dig deep and valdez just
dug deep and he just got caught with a
hell
of a uh a right hand
but he's hitting shakur in his hips
uh he's throwing right hand shakur is
letting his hands go
he hit him to the body he's valdez to
the body without this backed up he
thought the punch was low
and again
this is it right now these guys are are
out here
to give their all valdez you will know
who gave a hundred percent
uh if this fight doesn't go on his favor
because it's looking like she is picking
him apart looks like a vulture picking
at the bones of a carcass
but hey this is a live dead man here
walking
valdez gets punched in the groin
at the
bell five rounds to one stevenson is
taking it from him
[Music]
yeah stevenson is the yeah stevenson is
the better athlete we knew that going
into the fight like i told you before i
think oscar valdez is the dude that
gives you more heart than he actually
has gives you more ability from himself
because he dig down deeper i think
we wanted to see what stevenson had
excuse me
valdez has a cut under his eye
um
and we need we need we need to see
what's up
because i'm gonna tell you right now
edwin also is not going to let him take
a beating
so
uh
eddie even also will call the fight
but valdez is here to fight
he has to sell out and when i'm talking
about sell out people i'm talking about
he has to get over there by any means
necessary he has to rebuild with berto
duran this fight he has to dig deep and
he has to go for it get get knock out or
get knocked out
but he has to do it and he okay
okay i don't care what you got to do i
don't care what you got to do do what
you got to do man
all right so right now secure is back in
in the middle ring stevenson is doing
exactly what he does uh in the middle of
the ring his jab and his uh his left
hook
is definitely ridiculous
so you got valdez pushing him back
chasing him but stevenson is still in
control don't get it twisted see this is
the part where valdez has to make it
messy he has to you know when he gets
him up against the rope i don't throw
elbows throw right hands throw left
hooks
uh you know punch him in the legs slow
him down hit him to the ribs punch him
in the shoulders
do whatever you got to do but he's not
doing so much
he's trying all right so he's hitting
he's hitting secure with us and he's
shooting rights and he's going to his
body
defense is key for shakur
in this ring
uh he's moving and he's still
controlling valdez
all the stuff that valdez just did right
there that was positive
stevenson is still and
it looks like
valdez is about to go man
oh he hit stevenson with a left hook
stevenson does not look good
he hit him well and stevenson is walking
behind the ref
very good that's the difference man
valdez has that one punch joint but
stevenson's uh is blowing up on valdez's
eye
this is beautiful this is beautiful
stuff they're both out here
they're both out here stevenson is
controlling the reference allowing him
to measure valdez with that uh jab
and stevenson is doing what he does
right now about is trying his best his
arms is too short
and um right now
stevenson is measuring him with the jab
and he's shooting the right
straight i mean the left straight down
the pipe
and valdez is in the corner while
stevenson is pot shotting him
he keeps measuring him the ref hasn't
taken the point away and hasn't warned
them he's warned them one time right
here about it
but uh secure is definitely controlling
distance all you young fighters that's
out there watching controlling distance
is the key to every fight stay inside
your distance back up give ground when
needed spin off and throw your punches
valdez is trying to work
but his fuel work to be honest with you
and you gotta see
the the
10 second bell ring
six to one
it's it's it is apparent all right so in
in the ring
stevenson gets him out there
with that jab he jabs him out the jabs
him out there he jabs him out that he
jabs him out there and he shoots the
left under the body or he brings it over
the top
and um
he's keeping that distance on him and he
can't get past that distance is his
short hands i guess
[Music]
he said this is valdez round nah buddy
six one
okay
okay
i mean you give them that one round i
i couldn't find it
he got hit with a couple of shots that
wasn't delicious
you got to always ask yourself who would
you rather be in that round and that
round tells you who won
because us as humans we wouldn't want to
put ourselves in harm's way so
here we go
so round eight has just started
and um valdez is running chasing
stevenson across the ring he hit
stevenson with a right hand stevenson
ducks under it doesn't take any more
punches many more shots he's really one
shot and done and then he ties up valdez
so again so now
valdez gets hit with a couple of shots
from stevenson in the middle of the ring
stevenson looks like the bigger
stronger
more athletic fighter
at this point in time and he's
controlling distance
bigger stronger longer more athletic
fighter and we're seeing stuff that's
happening here which is outrageous so
valdez is trying to work valdez is
throwing to the body but stevenson hit
him with a hell of a body shot in
between punches
and he wanted it to be called low but
it's not cold low in valdez
um
they're back in the middle of the ring
which is again at the disadvantage
to uh valdez valdez is trying but
this is like a cat playing with his food
i just saw stevenson step in and step
out uh as a veteran move that he just
did he gave a fake with a pivot to the
body that he didn't throw stepped in
stepped out and he showed him something
and he went to the opposite side of his
body
very beautiful stuff you got stevenson
that's doing great work in the middle
he's hitting uh valdez to the solar
plexus taking his win from him
great stuff valdes is still trying again
he's still shooting the straight left
hand
and uh stevenson is digging the shots
under the ribcage of valdez
so
again
it's it's it's all about
what stevenson is
allowed to do
because he's range finding with a punch
he's uh allowed to work with the punch
so this is the apron remember i said
there's a 9th round tko i predicted that
um
valdez is trying his best but again the
superiority of stevenson is still
showing through valdez is throwing him
ripping shots in the center of the ring
but here we go again a lot of his
punches is slipping on the side of uh
stevenson and not actually hitting the
target to his main base
great punches off the top of his head um
again stevenson is controlling distance
that's the story of the whole fight okay
so valdez got in hit him with a left
hook and hit him with a left to the body
shot the straight right hand to the face
valdez is working but again
another round for stevenson i scotch 7-1
you could be generous
and give six to two
but come on man
our stevenson
will move up and weight class
he can move up about this because this
is true 72
looks like us
sony defenses
yeah yeah yeah
secures around here
[Music]
yeah these these they listen
high speed chest any time you see great
boxing and you have two fighters that
are presented to fight well with each
other they actually it's down to
matchmaking right and this is this you
have a boxer versus uh a fighter a
puncher
this is fantastic stuff they're both
trying to display their wears i just
feel that shakur is younger stronger
um
taller
and a little bit more
athletic
two undefeated champions
unifying here at 130 pounds
power punches stevenson and
ain't no mods man it's just me out here
i'ma have some mods later man
all right so valdez is shooting a
straight right hand which works against
southpaw that's right right here all
right
and then he hits the car again on the
lean back
there you go there you go he's digging
up through the body
um valdez has to stay
firm but i remember i picked this round
for stevenson so i expected tko in this
round
um he's uh has valdez back towards the
corner
and stevenson is moving him with punches
that shouldn't move out
um and he's hitting them
with uh straight right hands to jabs and
straight left
it's it's
it's
absolutely ridiculous remember i told
you the difference between devin haney
and shakur stevenson is i think secure
stevenson has
um more power in his shots than devon
haney
um you know but valdez is valiantly
fighting back
and he's hitting but stevenson is
throwing more up
in his repertoire he's more comfortable
you're watching both fighters you're
seeing a more comfortable more relaxed
fighter
in uh stevenson uh you know shooting
left uppercuts i mean shooting right
uppercuts
and uh
shooting jabs and controlling the fight
in the manner that he's controlling it
it's absolutely astounding to see such a
young fighter with such a command of the
ring
and
it's in it is dope to see
uh
valdez actually trying his best
against straight right hands about this
keeps trying to and he does land the
straight right hand
and he he really wants to
you know um put a hurt on shaquille
stevenson but
again
valdez is still pushing these punches
all right he's pushing he's pushing
stevenson
hit him with a left uppercut straight up
the middle i mean a right uppercut
straight up the middle
again this is beautiful
good work
oh he tried they both tried
they both tried
and again
well my prediction fell flat
9th round tko i give the round again to
stevenson's he backed him up the whole
round uh he had uh valdez out of swords
with a couple of the uppercuts a lot of
the straight uh jabs and the the
straight uh
left hand
this this absolutely ridiculous
um
[Music]
good stuff though
definitely good stuff
if
it's it's a one-sided
uh fight in terms of skill
but
again i have to give valdez his his
props
he hasn't given up yet his body language
hasn't said that
what's good what up what up what up
we're in here
he don't care man
i told you he brought his lunch pail he
hit it worse he hit it work
all right so he's going at him he's
going at stevenson he has stevenson in
the corner
and he's throwing right hands and he's
throwing left hooks and
again
it's like
all the effort that you put in is really
not building to anything uh constructive
and stevenson goes right back to his jab
his right hand
and is digging shots to the body
[Music]
so again here we go again stevenson is
right back at the same situation
valdez is still stalking forward
as stevenson taps his uh his guard
and he comes over uh valdez hits
stevenson to the body a couple of times
and he tries to bring it up
but it didn't really do anything
again
stevenson is right back to the control
oh good shots by valdez
valdez is definitely putting good shots
into work
but stevenson goes right back to
jabbing and using a sweeping um
left hook
over
there we go
stevenson is controlling valdez is uh
trying to box throwing the right hand
but stevenson is controlling valdez
jabbing jabbing jabbing
and then he'll stab him on the left oh
valdez is coming all right so
here we go
so stevenson is uh
backing him up to the ropes
[Music]
and he's going straight to the body of
valdez valdez is moving in mike tyson
style and he's going to
uh shakur's body oh my god
crazy uppercut
but i'm seeing more punches right now
this is his best round
best round by oscar valdez
uh valdez is leaping and throwing left
hooks to the body
excuse me
stevenson has not showed me the next
gear to his shots
[Music]
about this is is leaning to shakur's
body
jab right hand
but valdez is
is inside the pocket this is valdez's
best round
that's valdez's best round valdez put in
a combination so you got seven rounds
till um eight rounds to two eight rounds
to two
i don't know if she could take the round
off i don't know what happened
i don't know if he got hit with a shot
that actually affected him
i didn't see a shot that actually could
affect him
but um
[Music]
i think uh she could just took the round
off i guess uh he must have got winded
at some point in time but no
not at no point in time
do i think that uh
about this hurt him but again
it could be a stamina issue he could get
to the point where he hit the wall you
never know
yeah he's in too much control okay so
he's praying to god right now
so again
in the fifth round
has never been an issue here we go
championship rounds all right so here we
go championship rounds
let's go
round 11
48 stevenson is uh in the center of the
ring
doing this one too
and uh valdez is still throwing throwing
stevenson is
he's
shooting
he doesn't
but i'm gonna tell you right now man
valdez is fighting with all his heart
that's all you ask but um stevenson has
the most skill
he's going to valdez's body he's going
to his head
uh valdez covers and stevenson jabs to
the head now uh stevenson has gone to a
philly uh crab shell style
ala floyd mayweather
uh so he's uh spinning off and he's
shooting to the body all right so the
style that he's using right now is
actually uh really good
uh towards anybody that's in rushing
because you're able to turn and throw
uppercut straight up the middle which
he's doing
he's uh shooting a jab shooting the jab
and the jab is more of a touch me jab
the touchwiz of valdez's but valdes is
attacking he is relentless right now
and um stevenson is playing matador
all right so jab
jab oh
straight left hand straight down the
pipe
um
straight left hand again valdez backed
up
all right
all right straight left to the body
straight left right hand
all right so
this is the third time that the ref has
warned uh stevenson about measuring
valdez and valdez comes off the break
with uh double left hooks
so
stevenson is back in the middle of the
ring throwing combinations
to in honest with you valdez is trying
his best but
stevenson is so far on on the spell
cards to be honest with you
what's going to happen right
he has to valdez has to sell out while
this has to land something that can
actually beat this guy
but uh okay here we go that was
beautiful work
well there's is oh stevenson is shooting
a left and a right beautiful stuff
support wants this fight to beat right
here
oscar is having a little success in the
inside going down to the body but shakur
wants this type of fight
back in the middle of the ring
jab
last round
last round coming through right now here
we
[Music]
his go punch output of the night comes
in round number one stevenson is too
much for valdez
valdez is trying his best
he got a 7-4 uh valdez tried his best
there's no way i can give him that round
he didn't have control for the round at
all
yeah i gotta get that nine to two
this is the last round
valdez has to sell out in my opinion
um
yeah carnello isn't happy sitting you
know why would he be happy
you know that's his boys boys and
they're getting his boots rocked paul
so we got uh we got
three minutes to the end of this to find
out who it is
[Music]
all right here we go so now
you got valdez that's trying to sell out
and and stevenson is circling
circling going right back to his control
jab right hand jab right hand
jab right hand hook
[Music]
so he's throwing stuff right now valdez
is
oh he's throwing he's throwing
he's throwing
he's pushing but uh stevenson is backing
up
shooting the jab backing up
he's backing up he's he's not engaging
valdez in the manner that val does want
to be engaged in
stevenson is um not giving valve is
anything to
you
know keeps turning them
firing
he has uh valdez up against the ropes uh
trying to bleed time
um
jab hook to the body
uh from uh shakur valdez throws it right
over the top with a left hook
straight right straight right
from valdez
oh
oh
i think valdez is out on his feet
valdez is out on his feet i think and
she could ever realize that that's what
he has in front of him and he knows
because he landed a short right and but
valdez comes right back to work
and stevenson goes right into his shots
this is it
[Music]
this is beautiful this is beautiful work
right there i gotta respect
valdez for putting in the effort that
he's putting in stevenson is actually uh
shoulder charging and pushing him back
to the ropes
holding him bleeding time off the clock
and uh
shooting the jab
i gotta respect valdez i gotta respect
about this i gotta respect stevenson but
i gotta respect valdez because um
he's going up against insurmountable
odds and i'm pretty sure
uh he is fighting with a concussion at
least from round four
you know but uh stevenson
definitely uh it's beat him
and you can tell
you can tell stevenson knows exactly
he's the champion
he won
stevenson is running putting his arms up
in the champion pose
and the fight's over
i mean i i don't like to see my my
champions win in that fashion at the end
like that you know like taking my ball
and running
uh
yeah but yo float like a butterfly sting
like a bee
rumble young man wrong baby
the boy looked good
the boy looked good he passed his first
test this is his first test his first
real test i mean you could tell say
jamal herron was his first real test but
no this after valdez tess was crazy he
called oscar valdez out for years he
finally got the chance to fight oscar
valdez and um i guess uh eddie vanessa
knows exactly that this style uh is very
hard to fight um
and again i gotta give that ten rounds
to two
uh shaquar stevenson it was a utter
masterful master class of a fight
shakur definitely did everything to
obtain both belts
valdez can come back fight somebody else
but
stevenson is absolutely too much for him
100
this is definitely dope
uh nah b seven five now
your wallet
i can never give him seven five
you wallet
you're wildin that's absolutely nuts
plus
[Music]
fight is almost over i'll be able to go
to the bathroom drinking all these algae
drinks crazy gotta go to the bathroom
let me see let me see kisses on another
level yeah yeah yeah he's on another
level we want to see exactly who can
fight him and who can give him a tussle
right
and what division can that be um can
tank give him a tussle can tank give him
um what he's looking for can tank uh
davis uh
bring out the best in shakur stephen
because
it was times where he could have stepped
on the gas i don't think he stepped on
the gas i think it was times that he had
um
whatchamacallit uh out on his feet
and he was able to push it but he didn't
push it because his corner was probably
telling him uh
hold on don't risk nothing crazy you
know
this is a hell of a dominant performance
this this
yo
shout out to all the people that rock
with me thank you so much i do
appreciate everything man we're going to
look at the um the results because you
know it's not like it's a knockout so
we're going to look at the results after
the results is out we out
but again everybody is [ __ ] liked uh
subscribed
super chatted talked had a good time
listen man saturday night you ain't got
to be alone i ain't got to be alone we
could be here together talking fights
watching fights doing the thing combat
talk with the king all day this is what
we do this is what we about man
what's going on stevenson
just disrespected him
i must have missed five rounds of
speaker
yeah
he's big enough to fight you know
thank you thank you thank you brother
yeah let's let's just get the let's get
the official fishing before we roll out
the door you know you don't want to roll
out the door at the bar i'm talking
about a combat king yo it was a draw was
crazy i don't even know what happened
yo shout out to playstation
for having a commercial
on my pay-per-view
shout out to
playstation
xbox where you at man why you ain't got
a commercial on boxing oh you don't
think boxing is viable you only got
commercials on nba oh why because nba 2k
is on game pass uh for free this month
shout out to the uh
baby
oh man i gotta go to the bathroom back
this is crazy i gotta get that
uh fight paul scream man so i can just
go as soon as they ring this out i'm
gonna shoot up out of here boy i'm
shaking in my chair this is
crazy
[Music]
this is that's come on man read the
skull concept playing with me
taking off my jury ah
[Music]
[Music]
118 109.
[Music]
three belts
secure steers said all right guys i
catch you later thank you